[Musique]
depuis quelques temps un sujet fait
régulièrement l'objet de débat souvent
houleux la transidentité un droit que
revendique de plus en plus les jeunes
générations en 2021 alors ministre de
l'éducation nationale Jean-Michel
Blanquer met en place une circulaire
pour protéger les élèves transgenre à
l'école les élèves de collège ou de
lycée pourront se faire appeler par un
autre prénom que celui choisi par leurs
parents tout enfant quel que soit son
orientation sexuelle doit se sentir bien
à l'école vouloir changer de genre un
désir souhaité par certains enfants
comme Lili qui avait ému une partie de
la France j'ai su que j'étais une fille
vers la maternelle mais aujourd'hui des
voix tentent de se faire entendre à ce
sujet l'association SOS Éducation
parfois critiqué pour ses prises de
position a même lancé une pétition qui a
recueilli près de 20000 signatures non à
l'idéologie transgenre à l'école
changement de genre à l'école la
déléguée générale de SOS Éducation tire
la sonnette d'alarme elle s'explique ce
soir dans
TPMP juste on va on va lancer une
question qu'est-ce que vous en pensez
chez vous on va vous on va vous demander
parce j'a j'aime bien quand il y a des
questions mais ils ont pas posé de
questions c'est mal merci Sophie au duet
d'être avec nous merci délégé général
SOS Éducation et merci à mon Carl Z0
d'être là très content quand je te vois
et tu lances un nouveau média aussi he
part le magazine qui est formidable
envers des affaires un nouveau média
sous la forme d'une plateforme VOD ça
s'appelle car0.tv c'est un média dédié à
la lutte contre la pédocriminalité oui
c'est-à-dire que j'ai constaté que il y
avait énormément de documentaires qui
ont été faits de par le monde et que tu
trouves pas même sur Youtube ouais pour
des raisons mystérieuses et j'ai décidé
de racheter ces documentaires de les
traduire et de les diffuser et donc
c'est une petite plateforme tu me diras
c'est une niche ouais mais en même temps
je pense que ça touche énormément de
monde puisque je te rappelle que 1 sur 5
c'est une personne sur C qui dans sa vie
a été abusé c'est important de le faire
ça fait partie du travail aussi de faire
ça puis tu t'es surtout posé la question
pourquoi tu arrivais pas à remettre les
la main sur sur sur ces c'estd oui a il
y a des documentaires absolument
extraordinaire ouais par exemple tu as
tu as une bande aux États-Unis autour
d'un gars qui s'appelle team Balard et
eux ils font carrément c'est des anciens
navicil c'est des c'est des mecs c'est
des mec strong et on dirait un programme
Netflix sauf que c'est en vrai ils vont
par exemple ils arrivent en hélicoptère
en Colombie et ils sauvent des enfants
mais ça je je devrais le voir sur
Netflix ça pas d'accord VO parce que le
sujet gêne c'est toujours la même
histoire ouis c'est ce que tu nous
disais vendredi alors Sophie merci
d'être là et je voudrais vraiment avoir
la vie alors là des téléspectateurs et
des personnes autour de la table faut-il
s'inquiéter de cette affaire de plus en
plus d'enfants demandent à changer de de
sexe qui souhait changer d'identité de
plus en plus tôt c'est ça Sophie oui
c'est ça c'est incroyable c'est c'est à
partir de quel âge quand vous dites de
plus en plutôt en fait ce qui est ce qui
est important de de considérer c'est
qu'en fait en France comme dans beaucoup
d'autres
pays du Nord hein de l'Europe ou de
l'Occident en général enfin des pays
plutôt riches on a on a adopté un modèle
qui s'appelle le modèle de l'affirmation
du genre ressenti c'est-à-dire qu'on
considère aujourd'hui d'un point de vue
de société qu'il n'y a plus de réalité
du sexe biologique donc on ne reconnaît
pas le sexe de naissance de l'enfant et
on considère que l'enfant doit
s'autodéterminer euh quel que soit son
âge mais surtout quel que soit son
histoire de vie quel que soit son
parcours personnel et ça sans aucune
limite d'âge donc ça peut à 3 ans à 4
ans à 5 ans à 10 ans à à 15 ans et ca et
la la question que cela pose aujourd'hui
c'est qu'en fait on est passé à dans une
période où on on pouvait être au milieu
de lutte de classe à des luttes de sexe
et de Gen et cette lutte de sexe et de
genre aujourd'hui c'est un enjeu
politique majeur pour lesquel la plupart
des experts et des scientifiques ne sont
pas d'accord et sur lesquel il y a pas
de consensus et nous on considère qu'il
est dramatique aujourd'hui d'installer
cette idéologie dans les corps alors
dans l'école alors qu'on sait bien que
de nombreux pays font marche arrière
puisque c'est dangereux pour la santé
mental et évidemment physique des
enfants très important et le souci que
et c'est pour ça que vraiment euh cyrila
merci de nous donner la parole ce qui
nous ce qui est dramatique aujourd'hui
c'est que la parole sur ce débat n'est
pas apaisée elle est censurée
c'est-à-dire vous ne pouvez pas
aujourd'hui questionner la position d'un
enfant qui voudrait changer de genre
sans être considéré comme étant
obligatoirement transformbe or le sujet
n'est pas là et on sait bien on a
beaucoup de personnes d'ailleurs
transsexuelles qui prennent position
pour protéger les enfants et ça n'a rien
à voir avec le combat légitime
évidemment pour la cause des personnes
homosexuelles ou des personnes
transsexuelles ce n'est pas le sujet la
question c'est comment aujourd'hui on
voit exploser les les courbes
c'est-à-dire que dans l'histoire il
pouvait arriver un enfant né petit
garçon de se sentir petite fille et ça
arrivait très tôt c'est-à-dire
généralement c'éit entre 18 mois et 4
ans et cet enfant il était pris par une
souffrance tellement puissante sente que
ses parents ne pouvaient pas considérer
qu'elle était pas réelle et à ce
moment-là il était accompagné et tout le
travail des des scientifiques des
médecins des pédopsychiatres allait tre
de savoir si cet enfant il allait se
réconcilier avec son sexe de naissance
au fil des années ou si il deviendrait
une personne transsexuelle mais le fait
de d'être une personne transsexuelle ça
sous-entend des traitements
médicamentaux qui sont très lourds et
irréversibles des chirurgies invasives
qui sont très lourdes et irréversibles
et qu'à ce motif là faut pas se tromper
et vous dites vous dites bon donc pour
vous à l'école pour vous il faut plus
aborder ces sujets alors écoutez à
l'école il ne faut pas en tous les cas
mettre dans la tête des enfants que le
sexe biologique n'a pas de réalité
métabolique puisqu'il en a une c'est ce
que disent nos téléspectateurs voilà et
qu'il ne faut pas leur dire que à partir
du moment o ils sont mal dans leur
basket parce qu'on a tous vécu ça même
tout Petiton doit changer
obligatoirement de de sexe ou de genre
bien sûr je veux dire quand vous êtes
petit vous avez un copain qui a un
garçon et que vous êtes une fille vous
dites mais qu'est-ce que j'aimerais être
un garçon gar et quand vous êtes
adolescent avec l'hypersexualisation
actuelle l'obsession du paraître bah les
jeunes filles elles sont pas toutes
comme Kim Kardashian et à ce titre là
elles se disent mais si moi je suis pas
Kim kardachian est-ce que je suis
vraiment une fille et à ces questions là
il faut prendre le temps de la réflexion
parce que 80
% ce sont des filles qui veulent changer
de sexe aujourd'hui ouais à cause de
TikTok d'Instagram elles se disent ah
ell regarde j'ai pas le niveau bah je
vais être un garçon finalement ça avant
parce qu'il y a des standards maintenant
physiques qui se dit
ben on est dans la fure on marche sur la
tête et c'est là où moi je m'occupe des
enfants et donc je me dis là aussi on
touche aux enfants et on touche aux
enfants d'une façon absolument folle et
stupide et et il faut arrêter cette
machine qui est lancé c'est évidemment
pas contre les LGBT on a on a soutenu
leur combat on a
sout on depuis même il y a eu des bonnes
choses de ma 68 ça en fait partie et il
faut le connaître il faut bien leur
expliquer qu'on est pas contre eux du
tout on leur dit juste un truc pas les
enfants attendez qu'il soi puber c'est
ça Mathieu Matthieu tu trouves qu' c'est
inquiétant souffre c'est très inquiétant
parce que un enfant d'abord ça sédu qu'
on lui apprend des choses et
effectivement on est en train de lui
laisser entendre que il peut choisir sa
sexualité comme un vêtement une voiture
un
jouet effectivement 800 % ce sont des
filles aussi pour des raisons de
violence parce que le monde est de plus
en plus violent et que si on a un homme
on a plus de chance de s'en sortir
évidemment c'est très grave là où je
rejoins madame c'est que ce qui était
grave avant c'est que quand on souffrait
dans un corps ça prenait entre 5 à 7 ans
c'est ça pour changer il fallait voir
des psis des PSI des psis et des PSI ça
a été réduit donc effectivement tout le
travail des des professeurs aujourd'hui
des psis c'est d'aider à faire en sorte
qu'une personne trouve sa sexualité mais
en revanche elle doit pas la choisir ou
pire ne pas en avoir petite anecdote
mais qui m'a fait sourire sans me faire
sourire j'ai été dans un grand magasin
il y a pas très longtemps et LEF pour
moi enfin pardon mais je le monsieur se
retourne et je lui dis bonjour monsieur
et de manière un peu désagréable il me
dit qu'est-ce qui vous permet d'affirmer
ça bah tu as une BAR alors j'étais plus
vulgaire je lui dit tu as une [__] ou
non mais parce que non mais la manière
don il m'as parlé m'a agacé qu'est-ce
que ça veut dire alors on dit quoi que
dire on dans un monde malade il y a les
garçons qui ont des zizis les filles qui
n'en ont pas il faut tout faire en sorte
pour que les filles se sentent filles et
les garçons sentent garçons voilà et le
monde est bien fait c'est à peu près 50
50 sinon dans un siècl aussi alors
qu'est-ce qu'on aura je peux pas te dire
90 % d'hommes non mais c'est dis ça me
plait pas ouais Véronique tu es d'accord
non moi je voulais je voulais faire un
une moi je je suis complètement
catastrophée par par cet état de fête
surtout sur les enfants moi moi j'ai je
peux parler en en mon nom puisque moi je
voulais être un garçon quand j'étais
petite ouais je voulais être un garçon
mais je voulais plus être un garçon
parce que la permissivité pour les
garçons et tout ce que ça incluait
d'être un garçon mon frère il avait R de
sortir comment j' av pas de sortir parce
que ça tient ça aujourd'hui c'est ça qui
pour moi c'était le caractère qui
m'intéressait de liberté
ou
ch beaucoup de filles quicore
St qui veulent mais de là à changer de
sexe qu'un enfant veille à la limite
parce qu'il lui PLA pas pourquoi pas
qu'un enfant veuille s'habill en rose et
et pourquoi pas mettre vestimentairement
des choses qui lui plaisent plus qu'un
garçon veut mettre des jupes moi ça ne
me gêne absolument pas parce que c'est
une définition on a dit que les garçons
mettai des pantalons les fill et
pourquoi après tout gtier metta bien des
jupestait non les changer de sexe à cet
âge où rien n'est déterminé non mais ce
que ce que vous dites est très important
c'est-à-dire qu'effectivement on a une
génération précédente qui à qui on a
qu'on a éduqué parce que là il faut
savoir aussi qu'on prend l'éducation au
parents c'estàd qu'on on on on prend
l'éducation et l'autorité parentale des
parents pour instruire non pas les
enfants mais pour les éduquer de la
manière dont on considère qu'il faudrait
les éduquer c'estàdire dans la
déconstruction et notamment dans le
wquisme nous enfin la génération
précédente on a été élevé et on nous
disait tu as 1000 manières d'habiter t
cor de femme ou000 manièr d'héiter ton
corps d'homme alors il y en a un qui est
pas d'accord avec vous c'est Gill verd
en fait c'est une vision rétrograde de
la société madame que je ne partage pas
du jours partage pas votre vision non
plus vous car en fait madame le problème
c'est que hélas pour vous tous les
psychiatres vous démquent totalement à 4
5 6 ans aujourd'hui tous les psychiatres
consensusiss pe pasirmer ça parce que
c'est faux fin ma phrase d'où tu sors
ces chiffres 100% de toutes les analyses
que j'ai lu aujourd'hui pour préparer
l'émission à 6 ans une conscientisation
chez les enfants de savoir s'ils veulent
se sentir garçon ou fille et je félicite
l'éducation nationale française si tu F
à 6 ans parce qu'on va reprendre
l'exemple si tuasit à 6 ans t'avais dit
je veux devenir un garçon tu aurais dit
oui je l'aurais accompagné dans son
changement comme l'éducation nationale
heureusement à 6 ans heureusement sont
pas cap de à partir de 6 ans il y a une
conscienation 6 ans te dit papa je si
elle si elle souhaitait se sentir non
mais à 6 ans tu lui dis pas attends un
peu on va voir je parle avec elle et
j'accompagne le processus et Cyr ce que
je voudrais vous dire c'est qu'à partir
de maintenant l'éducation nationale
française heureusement ne vous écoute
pas puisque maintenant à l'école il y a
une prise de conscience de ça vous le
savez très bien et vous faites comme si
ce n'était pas le cas qu'il y a des
cours maintenant vous
parle les enfants pouront util parle pas
comme ça vous pas que je fais semblant
de pas savoir parlez pas les enfants
laisse la par s'il te plaît parlez pas
comm ça vous ne parlez pas en mon nom
que vous donz vot si vous me dites que
je dis que je ne suis pas consciente de
ce que vous dites c'est que vous parlez
en mon nom en l'occurrence je suis très
bien consciente il s'avère que quand je
prends des positions sur des sujets je
peux vous assurer un truc c'est que je
les ai plutôt pas mal étudié donc vous
parlez avortement par exemple madame
puisque vous êtes extrêmement
rétrograde vous êt très mal renseigné
moi j'ai pris la direction d' SOS
Éducation il y a 3 ans et demi faire
changer un peu c'est dur non mais
attendez parlez sujet dead sujet RAC
restons sur le sujet restons sur le
sujet alors restons sur le sujet les
enfants pourront maintenant utiliser
savez ce qui se passe est-ce qui est-ce
que vous savez ce qui se passe à un
enfant qui va prendre des bloqueurs de
puberté avant qu'il a atteint la puberté
cet enfant n'aura jamais jamais la
possibilité de savoir ce que c'est que
le désir c'est-à-dire que votre enfant
ne connaîtra jamais de sa vie le désir
sexuel et de relation intime avec qui
que ce soit alors moi je vais vous dire
une chose c'est que vous pouvez donner
des leçons au parents mais moi je vais
dire aux parents qui nous é si vous avez
votre enfant qui vous dit je me ressens
d'un autre sexe ou d'un autre genre il
faut l'écouter il faut l'accompagner il
faut l'emmener chez un pédopsychiatre
qui ne va pas lui dire oui il y a pas de
problème on va te filer des bloqueurs de
puberté et cet enfant on va
l'accompagner on va essayer de
comprendre pourquoi il souffre et on va
vérifier si cette souffrance n'est pas
autre chose qu'une disysphorie de genre
c'estàdire une incongruence entre le
sexe biologique et le sexe psychique et
à ce motif là peut-être qu'on attendra
que cette enfant soit formé parce que
sinon cet enfant on va l'enfermer on va
l'enfermer dans unem ou
enant qui aura lestitudesmotionn d'
enfant de 6 ans ça c'est votre liberté
de faire pour votre enfant pas% psychi
parce que d'abord le mien est contre et
ne sort pas comme ça des études comme ça
des
chray ang é par làdedans ont renoncé
depuis l'histoire de la clinique
Tavistock 10000 enfants en Angleterre
sont passés
cette et aujourd'hui ils ont tout arrêté
et il présentent am honorable vis-àvis
de ces gosses dont la vie a été foutue
en l'air donc ne dis pas de conneries g
s'il te plaî alors am qu'est-ce que tu
penses de ce que dit Gill Gill il
raconte n'importe quoi je sais pas mais
ils sont complètement tarrés c'est un
enfant à 6 ans il a pas de conscience
mais non il sait pas
en
VI pour laisse parler laisse par à vous
écouter à vous écouter pourquoi
l'éducation nationale a évolué c'est
parce qu'il y a des suicides c'est parce
qu'il y a des dépressions il y a des
enfants qui s mais écoutez-moi mais
caricaturez pas Conner mais non j'ai pas
dit à 6 ans là je viens pas de dire à 6
ans l'éducation nationale vient de
changer maintenant et permettre à ces
enfants 30 an d'avoir un accès aux
toilettes à la douche d'avoir un
changement de prénom possible parce que
leur comp les études scientifiques
actuelles prouvent que les enfants
accompagnés ont le même taux de
dépression et de suicide quand ils sont
adultes transsexuels il y a eu des
suicides parce que ce nétait pas pas une
étude documentée randomisée qui prouve
qu'il a une augmentation de suicide les
enfants sont dépressifs avant d'engager
uneisation inclusive pour que tout le
monde tu voulais ajouter quelque chose
moi quand j'étais jeune je voulais être
garçon aussi comme elle a dit Valérie
jeunest ma mère m'a dit
Val j'ai mis un jogging et des baskets
et ça m'est passé comme a dit la dame si
ça passe pas on verra quand ils seront
tu ne souffres pas une femme souffres
pas une femme donc voilà
donc une
femme TR tt on peut pas les laisser
choisir à 6 ans c'est pas un gamin qui
choisit et en plus ça s'appelle
l'autodétermination éclairée comme si un
enfant pouvait
décideritement à 6 ans de changer de G
alors qu'il n'a pas le droit de conduire
de boire de fumer que c'est n même pas
de détermination sexuelle
avant aura pas à cause des
avant la puberté la folie on marche sur
la lu demander d'ê d'accord de jamais
avoir d'enfants à 6 ans vous plaî Kell
non mais est-ce que des cours sur ça à
l'école quoi on parle de beaucoup de
choses mais on a pas parlé de la
pression aussi qu' avait les enfants
avant on avait la pression au collège au
lycée quand on grandissait maintenant dè
6 ans on leur met dans leur tête à eux
les enfants en leur mettant la pression
leur disant tu veux être un homme ou une
femme vous imaginez pr pour un enant ça
se trouve il se serait jamais posé la
question de sa vie et là on lui dit
chois le problème il est là poser la
question problème c'est qu'on doit
attendre la puberté comme vous le disiez
très justement vous le disiez la puberté
que il y a déjà énormément de problèmes
qui seront réglés avant mais seront pas
à 6 ans que je dis à pourquoi pas
pourquoi pas 4 an comme l'éducation
nationale dit que c'est normal vous
dites que c'est normal non je dis
l'éducation nationale a dit que c'était
normal parce que tous les psychiatres et
tous les
intervenants donc on est intervenu et on
a permis aux enfants qui 6 ans ont une
conscience de ça avec le parents on leur
a permis d'aller vers unangement et et
[Rires]
surout
lu je l'ai lu très
intéress l' enyé par ma jeai j'ai dit
vendredi
inér
pendant la pause disais qu'il était fou
franchement il est complètement fout à
une fille je comprends pas en fait tu
peux pas faire ça à une enfant de 6 ans
c'est peut-être un fils mais oui ou un
fils peu importe quand il est adulte je
veux bien après l'adolescence mais à 6
ans on lui a mis ça dans la tête et
c'est pas à l'école de lui mettre ça
dans la tête c'est dingue ce que tu dis
je te respecte énormément mais ce que tu
dis est dingue parce que tu dis on lui a
mis dans la tête bien sûr on lui laisse
le choix si on lui laisse pas ce choix
le petit va pas se poser la question
c'est l'enfant qui va faire la démarche
accompagnée par les par c'est ça vouspr
6 ans à 6 ans donc ton fils il va dire
je veux maintenant je veux conduire une
voiture tu vas dire ou pourquoi sera pas
député à 6 ans ça pour décider des lois
tranquille pas confondre la personne de
l'enfant comme un adulte en miniature
hein faut quand même replacer la
position de l'adulte et de l'enfant
c'est à l'adulte de protéger l'enfant
ouais c'est pas à l'enfant de protéger
l'adulte protéger tu protes oui vonique
tu veux en parler ou pas ouionique elle
m'a dit quelque chose dans entre tout à
l'heure pendant la pub que j'ai trouvé
extrêmement alarmante et intéressante
aussi elle me dit que les milieux par
exemple euh en fait les gens pour parce
qu'ils préfèrent avoir des transgenre
c'estàdire de transformer un garçon en
fille plutôt que d'avoir un homosexuel
et ça je parle pour ça elle me parle en
Iran ù elle me dit dans les milieux
américains très catoau il préfèrent
inciter les enfants à changer de sexe
très jeune pour pas avoir un
homosexuel parce que pour eux c'est une
catastrhe on marche sur la tête dans
cette société tê quand même en fait on
vit dans une société tellement obsédée
par l'inclusivité qu'on crée des sujets
là où il y en a pas l'enfance c'est un
moment où c'est normal de se poser des
questions de se sentir mal dans sa peau
il faut pas prendre le moindre signe
pour un bouleversement c'est normal de
se poser des questions changer de sexe
c'est quelque chose de lourd c'est
quelque chose de définitif on ne change
pas de sexe comme on change de t-shirt
et moi j'ai question mais ce que disait
Kelly ce qui est grave c'est pas ça
c'est qu'à l'école on leur met ça dans
la tête mais déjà ça c'est très grave
moi j'ai une question qu'est-ce qui se
passe si c'est une crise passagère
qu'est-ce qui si c'est un enfant qui je
suis une fille je devenir garçon en
Faour AR il n a pas de retour en arrière
on parle à l'école l'école c'est fait
pour apprendre pas pour influencer les
élèves c'est ça je suis d'accord qu'est-
dit non mais c'est c'est ce monde me me
dégoûte parce qu'eectivement il y a des
sujets il faut avancer mais le il le yel
le le genre tu es masculin féminin c'est
pas dramatique de enfin où est le
problème après à 16 ans oui on peut
faire un choix mais là tu te rends
compte tu vas tu vas dire tu vas dire
oui une petite fille tu veux devenir un
garçon et inversement sur quelle base
moi j'ai des enfants j'ai un enfant de 2
ans tu sais pas trop hein je je sais
combien j'en ai mais voilà si si demain
mon fils se pose des questions je vais
m'interroger je effectivement
l'accompagner pour aller voir un pédopsy
mais en aucun cas je vais je vais
l'acompagner pour dire tu vas changer de
sexe ah je veux être une fille très bien
on va che le docteur je vais tout couper
puis on change mais ça va pas la tête on
éta choqué avec l'istoire de la
disparition avec l'histoire de la
disparition de Mademoiselle tu te rends
compte j'étais dans l'éducation
nationale de dire à des enfants qu'
disant bonjour madame bonjour monur Non
non mais c'est n'importe quoi quoi non
heureusement que mademoiselle a disparu
en heureusemento heureusement que
mademoiselle a disparu d'après la
majorité des
[Rires]
psychiatres non arrête il a
raison comme ça c'est pas il a raison
mademoiselle qui a disparu c'est
dramatiqueiselle toi tu es content toi
mademoiselle est une honte c'est une
discrimination pour
les que
mademoiselle
excuse-moi mais je voudrais juste dire
quelque chose je vais dire pourquoi je
vous signale quand même que ça a disparu
hein donc là vous êtes tous à dire où
mais ça a disparu parce qu'on fait que
des conneries pas disparu mademoiselle
on
Paso pour parce que mademoiselle est
typant c'est une typologie dira une
femme mademoiselle ça veut dire signaler
qu'on pense ou qu'elle n'est pas marié
donc c'est la caractérisé pas caractéris
mais c'est vrai que maintenant tu as
plus le droit de dire mademoiselle par
contre par contre tu as le droit de dire
connard
quand
même non c'est bon savoir r qu'est-ce
que tu en penses attends après Matthieu
tu ça flatteur
moi on a eu ce sujet il y a 2 mois ou 3
mois ici on a déjà eu ce sujet là et moi
j'avais dit c'est pas aux enfants de
décider comme on fait tout cela avec
plein de convictions et plein de plein
de on est content on on a la ninac mais
on a aucun enfant on n'est pas concerné
et il y a beaucoup de parents qui
m'avaient écrit pour me dire moins il y
a beaucoup de parents qui m'avaient
écrit pour me dire on a on est vraiment
nous dans une vraie ance moi ce que je
pense c'est que 3 6 ans je pense que tu
peux pas décider parce que le chemin en
sens inverse c'est irréversible donc je
pense que 3 6 ans c'est tôt mais je
pense que 10 12 ans 14 ans peut-être
avec un peut-être avec un encadrement
peut-être avec un encadrement
psychologique à partir de 14 ans
pourquoi pas écouter plus l'enfant à
partir de 14 ans qu'à 6 ans parce qu'il
y a beaucoup de
par comme la majorité
tuoupon pas entendu vraors est plutôt du
côté de Gill [__] après le problème
c'est que Gill il éit un peu excessif
donc du
coup envie de dire oui alors donc en
fait moi je suis d'accord avec vous
c'està dire que si c'est à la mode c'est
non si c'est juste tendance c'est non
mais je pense quand même à beaucoup
d'enfants peut-être qui nous regardent
pas beaucoup mais quelques-uns ne serit
que même un ou deux qui nous regardent
et qui ont vraiment une dysphorie de
genre par exemple l'héroï du film petite
fille que vous avez sans doute vu ou
comme la petite Lili qui était venue ex
en fait la dysorie de genre c'est pas
juste pour se faire un tatouage ou un
piercing ou pour être à la mode ou pour
être tendance c'est une vraie souffrance
et vous le savez et donc voilà je pense
qu'il faut quand même les accompagner il
faut les écouter et on peut pas on peut
pas sous prétexte que voilà on est dans
dans une sorte de de fantasme wist en
disant voilà il y a une sorte de
déferlante de du par de mais non mais
absolument pas après puberté jamais de
la vie avec les enfants avant puberté
non jamais avant la puberté pas avant la
puberté alors répondre
Ouine d'accord avec nous parce que tu es
en train de faire du cas par cas et
c'est ce que nous on dit aussi du par
parce global
non parce que vous vous dites vous vous
arrêtez pas dire ouais mais moi aussi
quand j'étais jeune j'étais garçon
manqué doncis un surv c'est pas du tout
il s'agit pas du tout de ça en fait
c'est vraiment une souffrance
horribleuseuse je t'adore on parle
justement des gens qui mettent ça dans
la tête de personne qui pour un jour
j'ai envie d'être un
garçon
passé
avecé alors je vais vous répondre là
madame est-ce qu'on donne des cours de
dis à l'école oui on en parle dans des
livres parler les gens on met dans les
apprentissages voilà d'accord dans la
tête des enfants sans limite d'âge donc
même à 6 ans d'ailleurs vous avez des
petits livres pour enfant desè 3 ans qui
raconte l'histoire d'une petite fille
qui va reprendre la rentrée scolaire de
septembre en garçon et que c'est à
devenir garçon ça je pense qu'il faut
dans la tte dans la
tête que ça
existe rons au liv l faire poser
questions voilà je voudrait juste
répondre à ça insupportable il faut
laisser les enfants grandir il faudrait
juste proposer un tout petit peu
d'espace d'insouciance aux enfants et ne
certainement pas les mettre au cœur de
guerre d'adultes vous disiez monsieur
que tous les psychiatres sont d'accord
c'est faux il y a un combat de
psychiatres de médecins sur cette
question ne sont pas d'accord pour la
simple et bonne raison c'est que tous
les pays du Nord qui ont 10 20 30 ans
d'ancienneté sur l'accompagnement
reviennent sur leur position et qu'en
Suède et en Norvège aujourd'hui sauf cas
exceptionnel les bloqueurs de puberté
sont interdits et tous les traitements
sont interdits avant 18 ans c'est pas
par hasard si tout le monde était
d'accord pour dire c'était formidable et
que ça sauvait du des enfants tout le
monde le ferait parce que personne veut
la souffrance des enfants ça paraît
tellement évident ce que vous dites vous
avez raison ce qu'on connaî de
l'histoire de ce qu'on appelle la
dysphorie de genre qui devrait être
renommé incongruence que je vous
expliquais tout à l'heure c'està-dire le
fait pour un enfant profondément d'avoir
une différence entre ton sexe biologique
et son sexe psychique ça concerne un sur
10000 garçons depuis 100 ans et un sur
20000 filles c'estàdire deux fois moins
de filles aujourd'hui les statistiques
explosent c'estàdire que c'est fois 1000
des taux qu'on avait avant et c'est 80 %
de jeunes filles parmi ces jeunes filles
qui veulent devenir des gar
une majorité d'entre elles ont des
antécédents de situation psychologique
soit elles sont des jeunes filles qui
aurait dans les années 80 plutôt été
vers de l'anorexie mentale soit on a des
états dépressifs faut les
[Musique]
accag belle rentré INR al pas encore
dans le dictionnaire non c'est pas
encore dans le dictionnaire mal cherché
non non je dans le dictionnaire alors
l'incongruence c'est quand vous n'avez
pas d'alignement entre le sexe
biologique c'estàd que vous avez un sexe
de femme et que votre cerveau
psychiquement est convaincu qu'il est un
homme les années 50 c'est très tôt
c'estàd c'est 18 mois 4 ans dè les
années 50 on traitait l'incongruence
alors effectivement à l'époque il a été
traité de manière avec des pratiques
psychopathologiques très dures notamment
la castraction et aujourd'hui le le
l'attitude qu'on a c'est une attitude
presque de compensation parce qu'on a
honte de ce qu'on a fait dans ces
années-là aujourd'hui le problème qui se
pose n'est pas de reconnaître que pour
un nombre infime d'enfants cette
situation de souffrance elle est réelle
la caractéristique de cette situation de
souffrance c'est que l'origine est dans
cet nonalignement il n'est pas dans un
état dépressif et le problème qu'ont
aujourd'hui les médecins c'est
d'accompagner ses enfants sur un temps
suffisamment long pour pouvoir poser un
diagnostic véritable pourquoi parce que
si jamais on fait un faux diagnostic ces
enfants vont prendre des médicaments qui
devront prendre toute leur vie qui va
conditionner un des risques sévères qui
seront infertiles et qui n'auront pas
accès ajoutons ajoutons les labos et les
chirurgiens qui se font un pogon de
mammouth de mammouth bah attends chez
mammouth on écrase pas les prix là je
peux te dire là c'est un cauchemar
c'estàdire que les mecs il passent sur
le B des 14 ans c'est n'importe qui vois
on te surprin on te qui commence à
pousser et ainsi de suite et on te file
et les évidemment les hormones et donc
ça c'est il y a un pognon de bref tu
voulais parler depis tout à l'heure
après ona la réponse de G B non mais
parce que Gill évidemment il est
dangereux et surtout tu dis des bêtises
g alors quand tu dis des bêtises sur
l'amour et dans le Pr on s'en tape mais
quand c'est des sur des sujets
importants quand tu dis 100 % des
psychiatres on considère déjà qu'il faut
à peu près 40 ans à peu près 40 ans pour
qu'une étude puisse puiss être valable
par exemple aujourd'hui sur la GPA sur
tout ça sur savoir si de papas de mamans
ça donnera des enfants normaux pas
normaux on va attendre peut-être 20 ans
30 ans 40 ans pour voir s'il y a des
taux de suicide tout ça donc déjà c'est
pas possible parce que tout ça est
nouveau deuxièmement c'est pas la place
de l'école
effectivement on l'a dit donc c'est
c'est c'est ridicule pourant les enfants
se font harceler à l'école he quel
rapport on peut se faire harceler à
l'école donc c'est bien de savoir
exactement où tu te situes par et encore
une foiscole ne fait pas que instruire
l'école aussi a pas de rapport et encore
rapport
principe le
principe c'est d'être éduqué et si un
jour justement tu l'éduques mal et parce
que c'est un caprice et qui te reproche
le caprice là en revanche tu pourras
t'en vouloir toi toute ta vie s'il est
dans le mauvais sexe un enfant ça
s'accompagne ça ne choisit pas Ahou moi
j'accompagne mes enfants à l'école non
mais dans la vie ah
pardon avec votre idéologie qui n'évolue
pas en fonction des
to dans la connerie en tout casme tu te
sens évoluer toi g non mais j'aime bien
j'essaie d'être à-ce qui est idéologique
dans ce que j'ai dit non parce que c'est
bien dire l'idéologie mais qu'est-ce qui
estêes sans doute brillante mais perclus
d'idéologie madame mais c'est pas
Lear la S de maieim pas
beaucoup fait on sait que vous êtes
comme ça
mais mais il a raison on sait queit
d'idéologie savoir
pourquoi
répondzv-moi je suis pas à l'écolees
pas répondez-vous à la famille à la
famille de l'élève qui s'est suicid en
décembre 2020 après avoir été renvoyé
parce qu'elle ne pouvait pas je dis elle
elle ne pouvait pas porter de Jup
p
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
il j'en suis fier un seul cas un être
humain un enfant une enfant et vous vous
généralisezaboutissement c'est un
suicide mais non j'ai pas changé d'AV
tour vous allez pas
vous avant avant une transformation
physique une opération et et des
médicaments je veux dire on peut un
enfant très jeune en plus si vous lui
mettez une jupe et vous laissez pousser
les cheveux il leur a l'air d'une petite
fille donc rien n'empêche si jamais les
enfants ont envie de se sentir mieux
dans quelque chose pourquoi aller
jusqu'à l'opération pourquoi aller les
obliger pour aller pourquoi aller vers
je veux dire on peut l'accompagner
différemment pourquoi ne pas attendre
qu'il la puberté pour aller vers quelque
chose de plus parce qu'avant les
évolutions que je souhaite et que porte
forth heureusement l'éducation nationale
il y avait eu il y a eu des suicides de
gens su
sud des dépression non il y en a
pasvoir avancer là un
chifffre
diff temps qu'est-ce que tu as contre
Sophie là oui non mais
franchement d'avoir un débat apaisé sur
question sous un discours peut vous
séduire Cyril et j'en suis fort mari euh
parce que vous êtes très intelligent el
masque el masque sous ce discours une
idéologie une idéologie extrêmement
rétrograde t
association est très marquée à droite et
à l'extrême droite et je dis simplement
que ce qui est pas bien c'est d'orienter
un débat de société à l'ône de
conviction politique préalable voilà si
vous voulez savoir ce que je contre
l'avortement nous avons atint le
point l'association l'association n'a
pas été proche de la manif pour tous
madame l'association n'est pas proche de
milieu catholique très très très très
trèsie catholi inent
les
milieuxol
in vousêtes pas capable de regarder
enz lâch
votrez lâché votre P parce que vous avez
le sentiment ou que fait de m'o de là où
venez ça vous rend impossible de parler
d'un sujet aussi techque et concret que
la situation des enfants et de la prise
en charge d'enfants avant la puberté sur
des médicaments qui va conditionner leur
vie future contre l'avement madame ça
change tout le débat pardon mais
pourquoi tout à l'heure il arrête
direéondout
he alors
attentionès question mais je répondre
attendez dro ah bah tiens ça m'aa
étonné attends
excuse-moi
excusem
excuse-moi excuse-moi mais je croyais
que dans notre pays il y avait pas de
délit d'opinion elle a le
droittenant moi je suis pour
l'avortement oui mais toi aussi je veux
dire mais moi je suis pour l'avortement
mais elle a le droit d'être contre
pourquoi vouir
absolument C ils
font là un mauvais procès pas de réponse
est-ce que vous croyez que j'aurais
intervieé Sophie dans l'envers des
affaires souponnez qui est conchier ma
pauvre Bur frigide bargeot de la manif
pour tous vous vous souvenez de la
lettre que je lui ai envoyé vous savez
que je ne suis pas pas soupçonnable
d'être un mec de droite j'ai fait le
vrai journal pendant suffisamment de
temps pour que vous en rendiez compte
mais sur un sujet aussi grave qu'elle
soit pour ou contre l' l'appartement
l'avortement l'appartement c'est stéan
Plaz il est contre autre émission non
peu me chaud et peu m'importe ah non là
où je rejoins non mais c'est
son P qu' veut on est en République et
chacun pense qu'il veut sur ce problème
des enfants qu' qu'on emmène vers un
choix beaucoup trop tôt je me retrouve
parfaitement dans ce qu'elle dit après
elle a le droit d'être ce qu'elle
est